All right.
So let's shift to Jordan Peterson a little bit because you are a student at the
University of Toronto.
That's where he's been teaching for many years.
This whole kerfuffle over trans gender pronouns,
these stolen.
So like everyone's yelling at each other and hate each other.
I blame him.
What is,
what's the atmosphere like at the school?
Actually he's not teaching there right now.
We could obviously he's on tour in the book and the whole thing.
But has the atmosphere changed then?
Do you think it's directly related to some of the stuff that he on earth?
I think it has changed because there you can see the groups get and when someone
you know has a slightly right wing or,
it's funny cause I know Bateau bay associate individualism and the fact that
they associate thinking for yourself with being right wing,
it's like why would you want to do that?
It should not be anyways.
Why wouldn't you want to be right wing man?
Wait,
like what?
Um,
yeah.
Uh,
so the,
the,
when you're a little bit more right wing,
I guess they tend to say that,
you know,
you are joining Peterson fan and you hate transgenders and blah,
blah,
like there's a clear divide,
you can tell which side people are on.
Um,
but I,
yeah,
I think it was bound to happen regardless and just again,
because of the Trump presidency to like,
can we just blame Trump for everything here?
Yes.
You're in America now.
It's on your inbound to bring California too.
So that's how,
yeah,
yeah.
Watch out.
Um,
so you sort of viewed it as kind of a necessary evil that he sort of got this
stuff.
I mean,
again,
it goes to what we were talking about earlier,
like some of these people get these issues out there and then hopefully some
goodness,
yes.
After them.
Yeah,
definitely.
And um,
I think the other thing is Trump allowed people,
like I said earlier,
to think for themselves in the sense of understand that maybe not everything is
how it seems.
Maybe things that I'm learning is not exactly how it is.
And you know,
I,
you know,
I may disagree with his politics like,
because I'm a liberal in general.
Um,
but I do think that yeah,
it was bound to happen and Trump kind of shook things up and allow a lot more
people are engaging in politics now,
which is so exciting and also really scary at the same time.
Why is it that in,
I mean that's it right there.
I think just this morning I tweeted something out to that effect.
It's like,
wow,
it's incredibly exciting.
Doesn't mean things are going to be good.
I actually,
uh,
I believe things actually are going to get better because there's so many cool
new young people like yourself out there putting out ideas.
Like I have hope,
but yeah,
it doesn't mean that that's how it's going to go.
It might,
yeah.
It might go the other way.
Yeah.
But then the other thing is that because,
um,
the far left are scared that people are starting to,
you know,
do more research.
We first started to Google things nowadays.
Um,
they've started to ask why they want to control Google.
Exactly.
Eggs.
So now that you can't find any right information,
you can only find there's,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
but now they're changing definitions of things.
So I mean,
the definition of racism is no longer individual.
It has to do with power plus privilege.
So in other words,
only white people can be racist towards minorities.
Minorities cannot be racist towards white people.
Um,
they've also taken hold of the,
like student unions and Jordan Peterson has talked about this a lot.
I'm so sorry,
what was the question?
We generally was a about Jordan and being a student at University of Toronto.
Yeah,
keep going.
You don't,
yeah,
I just feel like I'm,
the student unions are just influencing a lot of the students in their
influencing a lot of the events that are happening.
They claim to speak on behalf of all students.
So,
and they claim that they're fighting against racism because I be defined it a
different way.
I mean,
was going to go against someone that says are fighting against racism and sexism
and every other buzzword that they can throw out there,
you have to accept it.
Um,
and because they've changed the definition of racism,
they've started to have events and there was a white privilege conference,
which I actually did a video on.
Yeah.
Why priors at Ryerson University.
So that's the way that they're countering it.
They're countering the facts with just,
you know,
we'll all die alternative facts with their own,
uh,
B s feminist studies ideas.
I don't even know.
But that's,
I guess the way they're doing it.
They're trying to influence students from schools something when they get out,
they can become more liberal.
So the things that Jordan talks about when he talks about the individual and
when he talks about why the government shouldn't be able to tell you what
pronouns do you use,
etc. Etc.
You see these things as all directly related to everything else that you've been
talking about here.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
And I think it's also about,
um,
sorry,
I just blanked it.
So
we were at a Jordan event,
that's where,
that's where we met about a month ago in Toronto.
And was it a white supremacists?
Oh yeah.
Pull in sales.
I was stoned on my way out.
Yeah,
I mean,
but were you surprised at all when you saw what type of and and an interesting,
diverse young,
I think most of them,
I've been telling people it's about 60 40 male to female,
but sometimes it's even closer to 50 50
yeah.
No,
I think it's pretty diverse.
And I've gone to several events,
like a political events.
I guess where I look in the crowd,
I'm like,
wow,
there's a lot of minorities here.
There's women here,
there's one here,
there's everyone here.
And sorry,
where I,
where I blanked was the idea that you can't,
you can't debate something.
That's where that was the whole PD.
I'm like ranting here.
Sorry,
here's the,
and gets me like all excited cause I was there.
So he had this effect on people.
But the fact that you can't debate certain topic,
the fact that you can debate whether or not we should use certain pronouns
because they say,
well you're questioning my identity.
You're questioning me as a person.
My humanity,
they turn it around and make it sound like you hate that person.
And that's the thing is it's not like I agree with Peter Cena.
I agree with the,
you know,
the students.
I just want to hear both sides.
That's all I'm asking for.
Something we can all make an informed conclusion,
but they don't want you to hear both sides.
They want you to hear their side.
And that is the only side you see what happened with like Lindsay Shepherd as
well,
where she,
you know,
played a Peterson debates where they're all sides and they don't want you to
hear that.
They only want you to hear their side.
And that's where,
that's one thing I hate the most is just the lack of discussion.
Yeah.
So I'm glad you brought up Lindsey,
because that also is happening in Canada.
That was at Wilfrid Laurier university.
Now there's a lawsuit that she's involved in and suspect
I read some of the initial brief,
I mean,
I think this thing is going to be a bloodbath for the university.
Um,
but what does that say is happening in Canada in a larger way?
I think you've kind of hit on this a little bit.
Like you guys were almost having like this,
like Trump hangover or something where,
or even the black lives matter thing.
Like it didn't start in America as you said,
race relations were different in Canada.
I would argue they're still great here.
It doesn't render.
Canadians are just nicer.
Okay,
great.
Canadian just generate you guys.
We've done two shows in Toronto and the shows were totally nice and pleasant.
But like we've gone to some other cities where,
and I find it's usually in the progressive cities.
So it's been in,
you know,
San Francisco and it's been in Seattle and a couple of the others where the
crowds are the craziest most rockets,
which is what I liked was cause they kinda,
they need his message.
Toronto,
you guys are very pleasant,
very pleasant.
We're getting to a point where we need his message.
I think it's,
it's getting a little scary,
especially with Trudeau as our prime minister.
He's kind of cow towing to a lot of the social justice warrior.
And the fact that he's even,
you know,
talking to black lives matter Toronto,
who,
you know,
the leader,
one of the leaders said she wants to kill white man.
She tweeted that she wish she can kill all white men and the other one actually
stole $300,000 from my student union,
stole it and said the she on her last day.
She filed her over time and she's filed thousands of hours of overtime and said
she filed $300,000 worth of over our entire budget of our student unions budget
a third and here's the best part of it.
She files dot.
Obviously there's alerts that go off.
You can't take that much money for what are your student union president?
$300,000.
Sure.
There aren't that many hours in the day,
but here's the thing.
She claims that the majority of those hours come from work that she does for the
black community,
for like black lives matter.
That doesn't count.
No one is asking you that's not affiliated with the school.
No one's asking you.
Whatever you do at home has nothing to do with that.
Anyways,
the school obviously said they wanted the money back.
They try to sue her and they started a whole campaign saying,
my university is anti black.
And then they started to put posters up.
They got gathered a bunch of people saying that they're their only suing her
because she's black.
You stole 300,000.
You took $300,000 girl,
like,
are you because you're a black?
Are you kidding me?
Does that not even,
anyway,
she,
you know,
they vandalized the student union.
They have like megaphone starts yelling,
saying anti black racism happens here.
Hence,
and it was just this whole ordeal.
Like it's,
Ugh,
Gosh.
Anyways,
what does it sound the best arguments to get people your age to wake up to some
of this stuff?
Like,
I know obviously they're watching your videos.
That's like probably your,
your prime way of doing it.
But have you found simple arguments,
simple phrases or whatever that you can use to get some people out of this?
Uh,
everything can be explained the way through a socioeconomic standpoint.
You,
uh,
there are a lot of the issues that the black community faces because they're
poor,
which is the same issues that poor white communities face as well.
And,
um,
I,
you know,
there are examples of black Americans and black Canadians that do do well to do
well and a,
you have to look at why they're doing well.
Okay.
So they have higher education.
You know,
there's,
they're both parents are at home.
There were all these different factors to look at and then it's like,
oh,
so it's not just the color of my skin,
it's either choices or I make or the area I'm in,
the surroundings I'm in or the school I went to rather than just,
it's the color of my skin.
Um,
but I think you just have to break it down to that before a lot of people can
understand where I'm coming from and why I think a certain way.
Um,
it's just,
it's easy to just to say,
well,
it's because I'm black and I'm not doing as well.
It's,
no,
there's,
there's so many different ways to explain it.
How did he rub off all the stuff that they must say about you?
Because I have enough friends that are black conservatives or,
or are kind of liberal and whenever you want to call it that.
The things that I see get that gets said about them all the time.
Every time Larry elder comes and does my show and I look on Twitter,
the things that,
the things that the supposedly tolerant people,
right?
The progressive's,
the left,
these,
that they say about this man who I know is being authentic.
Um,
well,
it's ridiculous.
I mean,
I get a lot of,
uh,
hate comments where,
you know,
they'll call me coon,
they say hate myself.
I want to be white.
All these different things.
I,
it's the one part is like me speaking this way or speaking,
I guess,
I don't want to say proper English per se,
but I tried to be white.
I'm trying to be something I'm not in.
It's like,
why are you fitting people a race in a group?
You're just allowing white people just to say,
well,
black people are just dumb.
Because if you saying we all act the same way and we should all think the same
way,
that means you can,
every black person can be explained with one statement.
That's not fair.
Let us all be individuals.
In fact,
you should be fighting for us to be individuals and have our own ideas.
Why are we trying to form groups?
And then they wonder why,
why there's all these like white supremacist groups forming up.
Cause you've already,
it's a site's thing.
You said there's our side and there's your side.
So you're like,
okay sure we'll form a group I guess and go against you.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean I don't,
a lot of the hate comments are just useless.
I ignore the epithets,
but I do try to understand a lot of the criticism and again,
it's just not understanding where I'm coming from.
It's not,
you know,
getting their stats from the right place,
the root.com or onion.
It's not somewhere to get your facts
but,
or like that you compare those.
But when I,
um,
you know,
get into a detailed discussion with a lot of them,
then they understand where I'm coming from and it's like there's this light that
kind of shines.
And I do that at my school a lot as well at where someone that absolutely hates
me,
I'll spend a whole day talking to them.
And at the end I call it like,
it's really awful to use this conversion therapy or awful.
Um,
um,
you're not electrocuting no,
but by the end of it,
it's like their minds are blown because they just believed everything.
Black lives matter said everything the mainstream left media have said.
So it's,
I think it's just,
you just got to talk to them.
They don't want to talk.
They're stuck in echo chamber.
Do you see this intersectionality and this combining of perceived depressions,
something that
will just sort of crap out under its own weight.
So like for example,
if you're going to keep saying,
well,
black people should,
or this minority,
whatever that might already is,
should get easier entrance to this or access to this or whatever.
What you're actually saying is,
well,
other people are going to have to be punished based on their immutable
characteristics.
We see this now.
I mean I see a massive split happening with the Asian community right now in
America because by every metric that we judge success,
they are succeeding at extremely high levels because of hard work and education
and commitment to family.
But if you're going to start saying,
well,
we're going to have to take less of them because we have to take more of other
people.
You're actually setting these groups to hate each other.
Yeah,
that is so
danger.
Exactly.
And you're telling one group that they can't do it on their own.
And um,
there are some studies,
I forgot who it was who wrote it,
but it was called the mismatch theory,
which is,
um,
a lot of the student minority students are getting thrown in universities or to
not qualified actually turn out worse when they come out.
They don't get jobs because they don't have the actual skills that they needed
to get in.
But yeah,
it creates this kind of tension.
Why would you tell someone that,
you know,
they're more important just because of the color of your skin.
It's going to piss other people off.
Um,
it's,
I don't think that's a way to move forward.
I don't think that's a way to progress.
But yeah,
and the whole intersectionality thing,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
The Pride Parade I guess in Toronto is an example of that.
It's like my issues are more important.
And then obviously the Lgbtq community,
they all hated that and they were all very upset with it cause it's like pride
is one of the most inclusive,
you know,
events in,
in the,
in the city.
Why are you trying to ruin it and say this is a black thing.
It's an everybody thing.
We're,
we're all advocating for everyone here.
So it's,
it's,
they're just going to,
yeah,
they're going to ruin themselves if they keep just adding.
Yeah.
Speaking of that,
I saw the thing that you did.
You are not happy when they put the black and brown stripes into the rainbow
flag,
which I also thought was completely [inaudible].
The whole point is that this is for everybody.
We're not looking at all your differences and all your races.
Yeah.
That's one thing.
It's like reverse segregation.
I really don't get it.
The white privilege conference at Ryerson University.
Yeah,
that's reversed segregation and I actually gave him the benefit of the doubt.
I'm like,
I'm going to ignore the name.
I'm going to actually try to see what they're trying to teach.
And ultimately the end,
the conclusion of this event was listen to people,
listen to what people are saying.
So anecdotes only listening to people their feelings.
So it's like that's not how you form a society.
It's the majority were white women.
They were just sitting there hearing black people tell them,
just listen to our stories because we know and we experience it and you know we
have to have,
you know,
black spaces.
In fact there someone at tweeted during the event saying,
I'm a woman just rules our hand to speak while whitesplaining wait for the,
for leader where we have our white corners or we can talk about,
you know,
are,
what is this?
What kind of society are we preparing herself for?
It's literally reverse segregation or segregation in the true sense of the word.
And I,
yeah,
I really don't.
What
do you make of the guilty white allies?
Those people,
you know,
when I've had a,
I know you met Frat Weinstein from evergreen and Heather,
his wife.
Um,
one of the things that fascinated me most when he was going through the ordeal
there was that he said he never feared the black students physically or the
brown students or whatever it was.
It was the white allies he said that had this sort of look in their eye.
Like they were the ones that could get violent.
And I've seen that,
that look,
what do you make of that sort of agenda?
Hatred.
Cause it's hard to,
to,
cause if you're not black then,
I mean,
they're trying to explain it.
If you're not black thing,
you don't experience it,
then you don't understand it.
So I said,
why I lie,
you have to just take everything,
you know,
an activist says to you as fast as this is what is happening.
Um,
one of the speakers,
actually he did an interview for the Toronto Star and they asked him and I was
like,
okay,
what,
where do you see white privilege in Toronto?
And he said,
literally,
I mean,
I'm paraphrasing,
but he said,
when you walk into a store,
black people or black people have to think about the fact that people are
watching them.
Okay,
sure.
I was like,
fine,
whatever.
But apparently black people have to pay for items in one section before they can
move to another section.
So they don't get accused of stealing.
That's his,
his,
he got a chance to tell us what white privilege is.
And that was his example of white privilege.
Is that happening?
No,
it's never happened.
I've worked retail for like the most of my life.
One,
you're gonna like pay the kid section before you go to the men's section.
Like what world is this guy living in?
It blew my mind.
And another one,
you know,
did an article where it's how the outdoors is racist and how,
people feel like the,
you know,
skiing and hiking and everything is a white space.
And therefore black people don't want to go to it.
And it's like who you're saying it,
you're the one that are making these claims.
Why are we there?
It's just more division.
It's more like I just,
it pisses me off.
Yeah.
You know what?
We're in it because you're visiting La for a couple of days.
I don't have a ton of time,
but maybe we could go on a quick hike and see what happens.
I know
exactly,
but it just like,
you're obviously don't care about the betterment of the black community cause
you wouldn't be talking about these non issues.
You're in the stage.
You can talk about,
you know,
uh,
sorry,
how the education system works.
You can talk about the war on drugs.
You can talk about the prison system,
but yet the amount of people they got to protest the Trayvon Martin,
you know,
uh,
shooting.
If you can get that many people to protest the war on drugs,
you can probably make a change.
But no,
they're going to focus on,
you know,
I think police shootings,
it's one of the least things that are actually affecting black Americans.
But yet that's what they want to put their focus on.
So how much of the root of that is just lazy thinking?
Like it's easy to get people gender up about a shooting per se,
and I'm not,
I'm not diminishing that are wrong.
Obviously.
It's all clear.
It's easier to take all of the antidotal stuff,
the woman at the shopping center who this happened to her that,
yeah,
it's always easier to do that than to really be like,
let's really look at the prison systems,
which I would be for looking,
I would be figuring
out ways that we can do better education to minority communities that had been
neglected.
All of those things.
But those things aren't really sexy.
They're not like the things that get people out on the streets for more than a
day.
It's the other stuff.
So part of this is just human nature,
right?
Yeah.
I totally agree.
I mean,
I,
I can base all my arguments on anecdotes,
but that doesn't like,
that means nothing to me.
I can just say,
oh,
well this one day I've lived in Toronto all my life and I've never experienced
racism.
I'm not going to use that as facts,
but yeah,
but it's so much easier to do.
So it's so much easier to,
you know,
if playing with the heartstrings and say like this is what's really happening.
But it's just,
it's just sad that there are actual policies that you know,
can be changed or put in place that could actually uplift the black community.
But you know,
none of the people that are that claim to be the activist care,
especially the celebrities,
which really annoys me.
Beyonce and Jay Z,
all they do is talk about,
you know,
black rights and blah blah.
Why don't you use your billion dollars to,
you know,
create some rehabilitation center for people that are getting out of prison.
Why don't you try to fight for the war on drugs?
Like it's all these things where it's,
it's,
yeah,
it's easy just to say,
oh look,
there's a shooting.
You know,
this is what black people experience every day.
And you know,
white people are racist.
The end.
No,
it's theirs.
I don't know.
It's easier for them to just to say,
look at this anecdote in this shooting and that's what's affecting us.
But there are so many other things that could be done.
A little bit of my appearance at University of New Hampshire when those kids
were,
oh yeah,
yelling at me and when that one woman who,
I don't think it was a student,
I think she was either a mother of a student or,
or than advisors when she kept saying,
you know,
these kids pointing to the black kids could get shot when they walk out of here.
She's talking about it University of New Hampshire and it's like,
I actually,
that was one of the only moments where I didn't know what to say because it's
was so crazy to say that like you're not going to be shot and you walk out of
here.
And I think I maybe said something to that effect,
but like,
it's like that's really dangerous,
that line of thinking.
I totally agree.
And I was actually having a,
I went to a comedy club the other day and there's this guy on stage.
He was like typical inner city black youth or whatever.
And uh,
he,
after his sat,
he came to sit in my table,
everyone was gone and he made a comment saying,
um,
wow,
it was really hard to be a black woman in this country.
And this is again,
this is Canada.
I feel like there's no excuses for Canada,
like,
get out of here.
Um,
and then I asked him,
okay,
how,
and he's just like,
I don't know,
it's just,
it's really hard to be,
you know,
a woman in black.
I'm like,
yeah,
I get the whole woman thing cause you know,
men or if you know,
physically bigger and blah,
blah,
blah.
Um,
but why is it hard for me to be black and Toronto specifically?
And he's like,
you know,
cause you know,
there's just white privilege.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
Give me two reasons.
Give me to concrete reasons could not come up with one because there isn't,
you can't come up with,
when you have to use the anecdotes,
you have to use the,
you know,
if you walk out in the street,
you're going to get shot.
Why,
what are the statistics of people that get shot by police?
Oh seven get shot by police per year.
And it's not recorded by race.
And it's also doesn't tell us if they're armed or on our seven people.
And you're telling me you're more likely to walk out the door as a black person
get shot.
That's not an epidemic.
You know,
what's an epidemic?
The crime in black communities.
That's an epidemic.
But you want to ignore that and just talk about the other yeah.
Anecdote that pull at the heartstrings and make people feel guilty.
And uh,
it's,
it's a waste of time.
It's such a waste of time.
Oh,
what do your parents think about what you're doing?
Uh,
well they are conservative,
so they love it.
So what makes you not conservative?
We've,
so if someone was to say,
you are,
you're conservative,
I watch your videos.
Yeah.
Talk about conservatism is not that bad.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Why would you not say you're sort of putting aside the exhaustion of labels,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
well I will say specifically conservative.
So,
I guess I do believe in like lower taxes and some science.
Um,
I do believe in the free market.
I do believe in,
you know,
less regulations,
all that fun stuff.
But at the same time,
I do think that there should be some sort of social safety net and uh,
you know,
living in Canada where there is,
I'm sorry,
free health,
not free healthcare,
universal healthcare and you know,
at the university education,
the education system is amazing.
The,
the funding for the education system is amazing.
Um,
so stuff like that where I think I'm a little bit more liberal where I do think
the government should help in some way,
but it's because I'm used to it.
It's what I grew up with and I haven't really seen anything different.
And it works.
It works fine.
Um,
so I guess that,
and I'm pro choice,
I'm so stuff like that where I really do stand firm in my liberal views and
ideas and then,
yeah,
I'm fiscally,
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Wow.
We're pretty much aligned.
[inaudible] I finally found somebody,
now we can go out hiking yet or we can start beating people.
Exactly.
I don't know what supposed to do once you find an ally but you start attacking
other people.
I think that's how it works.
Something like that.
Where do you want to go with all this?
I've seen,
I've seen your channel grow.
I think obviously,
you know,
have a new here at all.
It'll help boost your profile a little bit.
You got to go into politics.
What are you going to do?
Prime Minister of Canada,
take out that Trudeau guy with his fancy socks.
What do you mean?
Oh Gosh.
Um,
well maybe,
maybe Peterson will do it,
but you could probably be in his cabinet.
Yeah,
definitely.
Sorry.
Well I am enjoying what I'm doing now and I'm quite surprised that people even
enjoy watching my videos.
I think it's cool to do something you love and people like it as well.
Like I really am having fun doing it and I think I would probably go into
politics later in life.
I mean I am doing political science.
It has to be useful somewhere.
I've been toying around with law,
but again,
I'm not sure if I really want to be in,
you know,
the whole,
I don't know if I want to deal with law school.
Um,
but,
and I am starting actually a podcast with my boyfriend,
which I would be uploaded very soon.
Bye.
So,
yeah,
I,
the way we should tell people yes,
they'll find out otherwise your boyfriend is white.
Yes.
Claim writings,
which means you could have potentially children who look black.
They might look white,
they look a little bit of both.
You've talked about that a little bit.
It doesn't really matter to you.
No,
of course not.
No.
Uh,
yeah.
My boyfriend being white has been used as like an attack against me saying like,
wow,
look at you.
Uh,
what did they say?
Sleeping with the devil or something like that.
And it's just seems like a decent fella.
He's a great guy and play Nintendo.
No,
he's a great guy.
But again,
it's,
it's the whole idea of why are you creating more divisiveness and then saying
you want equality.
Why are you saying a black woman being with a white man is bad and then say,
wow,
white people are mean to me.
Like you either want equality or you don't,
you either want individuality or you don't pick one.
You can't have both again and it,
sorry.
But yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm not 100% sure where exactly I will be in the next five years.
I'm having fun with what I'm doing now.
I worked for the National Post,
which I absolutely love.
And then I have the podcast coming.
So that's what I'm going to do for now.
And maybe I'm,
I get into politics but oh,
it's so messy.
The fact that you even are go in that far right now you're doing it.
Oh God.
I hate to tell Ya.
I can see it now.
How exciting.
I'll have somebody to support and care.
You know what you get,
you do something in Canada where you run and you become something,
mayors something whenever you want to do,
I will consider moving.
Oh my [inaudible] you can pull it off.
It'll be a big freaking test though.
You see what happens.
Definitely think I do.
Okay.
There are white guy.
Oh No,
I'm sorry.
You're done.
For,
you're going to have to start giving me like half of your page just cause you
know racism and stuff.
Yeah.
But I think one thing that I would actually probably like to do,
which I probably will not be able to,
but uh,
to do a lot of work in like inner city communities.
Cause I've,
I,
I don't want to say I've lived through it,
but I understand what's going on there.
I understand that,
you know,
there's high crime understand that in some neighborhoods the schools aren't as
good for Canada's a little different.
But I'd like to do some work there where I can kind of tell them,
hey,
I got out and here is what I did to get out.
And you can do it too.
There's so many,
there's opportunities there for you.
Like if you were poor minority,
you know,
child right now,
please just try your hardest at school,
get an education.
It's literally one of the greatest opportunities that you can have.
And you're more likely,
I mean you probably not 100% great,
but you're more likely to be successful if you get an education.
And that's the one thing a lot of black people are lacking is the education
component.
And um,
you know,
we don't really have like the war on drugs and everything.
So it really is weird for me that in inner cities of Toronto where there's still
this very high crime,
there's still this tension.
Um,
but you know,
that'd be ever heard of the Woodson center by any chance.
It's a nonprofit organization.
It's located in DC.
Um,
but I've been working with them for some time and they basically do the same
thing.
They go out to these neighborhoods and they help students and they have such a
good success rate.
They held them in high school.
Cause that's the other thing is that a lot of black kids are not even graduating
high school.
Of course they're going to go into crime if you're not even graduating high
school.
Um,
so yeah,
they work with a lot of students there.
They,
you know,
have rehabilitation centers.
They help.
You'll,
uh,
black,
sorry,
black Americans reintegrate into society like it,
stuff like that,
where it's these grassroot movements.
And I would really like to do,
and I know it's a,
it's a big dream,
but I think that's where I would probably be happiest,
is where I can show people how it's done and help them.
And hopefully everyone can copy that and say,
Oh,
this is what we're supposed to do and all of that.
But awesome.
I love it.
And I have no doubt that you're going to do it.
And you guys can follow this future member of Canadian parliament on her youtube
channel right here.
It's youtube.com/my name is Josephine.
Yeah.